[Music]
on this saturday night
cra accounts locked concerns about hacks
at canada's revenue agency
they've also made it really easy for
criminals to access this money
will this delay tax season an outbreak
at amazon's facility in ontario
why the company is appealing the closure
plus the growing calls for new york's
governor to resign
after seven women come forward with
complaints
and the oldest person in canada gets her
shot
it was wonderful she's now lived through
two pandemics
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us for the second time in less than a
month
tens of thousands of canadians cannot
access their cra
accounts the tax agency has locked more
than 800
000 online accounts because login
information and passwords
may have been obtained by unauthorized
individuals
our chief political correspondent david
aiken has been looking into the security
concerns
what you need to know david
well rob and the online accounts were
locked overnight usernames and passwords
revoked by the canada revenue agency
in what the cra called a preventative
measure
aimed at stifling attempted identity
theft or online fraud
saturday's move comes nearly a month
after an unspecified number of accounts
were locked
after an internal cra analysis revealed
some credentials such as
user ids and passwords may have been
compromised possibly even obtained
by an unauthorized third party tax
experts believe that in making it easy
for canadians
to get the serb or other pandemic
benefits
ottawa also made the cra a target for
fraudsters
there's free money out there and so the
government's really made it
easy for canadians to access this money
because of the
pandemic that's going on but they've
also made it really easy for criminals
to access this money
the cra is already contacting affected
users with instructions on
how to reactivate accounts that said
impacted users can still log
in using their online banking
credentials or
they can create a new user account
and consumers can still file tax returns
using the cra's online net file service
but until those accounts are reactivated
locked out consumers will not be able to
manage direct deposit info change
addresses or
sign up for some federal government
benefits the government meanwhile
is coming under fire for not moving
quickly to reactivate accounts of those
locked out
a month ago and for moving too slowly to
help victims of fraudulent activity
on their cra accounts i'm really
surprised i haven't extended the tax
deadline
with all the problems that kovit has
caused a lot of people
the individual tax filings are going to
be very difficult this year
in the house of commons friday the
liberals promised no consumer
would face any financial losses the
canadian revenue agency takes the
protection of taxpayer information
very seriously we have put in place
robust safeguards in place to identify
fraudulent emergency and recovery claims
we will work with the victims of fraud
and they will not be held responsible
for any money paid out to scammers
using their identity and the cra is also
warning that
account lockouts and other preventative
measures are not
isolated incidents and may become ever
more frequent
to safeguard taxpayers information robin
david aiken in ottawa thanks david the
canadian military has been blocked by
allegations of sexual misconduct in its
most senior ranks
both of the country's most recent top
military commanders
are under a military police
investigation the former chief of the
defense staff
general jonathan vance has denied he
acted inappropriately
but one woman who claims she is the
victim of sexual misconduct
says the problem extends beyond the
military and into the department of
national defense
a former combat arms officer alex eau
claire
is now a civilian dnd employee in an
exclusive interview with our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson
eau claire shared her account of an
alleged sexual assault she says
she experienced at the hands of a
department executive and the lack of
support she felt
when she first sought help
i tried to report it and
the answer i got was that because there
was no
did i have any dna evidence did anybody
witness this
if if the answer was no and if you still
needed a job
it was his word against mine and so
basically shut your mouth
and carry on that was the last i heard
of it again and so i dropped it
i dropped it i let go and
there there is really nowhere to turn to
who's going to believe me i'm just a
young
young woman who
has no proof who's going to believe me
i'm not sure the military
police and and again i'm dated so maybe
they they're
they are better equipped now they just
weren't equipped to deal with
these types of issues also you lose all
trust in leadership
i already didn't have very much to begin
with but
you lose all trust in leadership and
on the monday morning i walked into his
office and i said it's never ever going
to happen again ever
ever if you cannot control yourself
around me
i'm done i'm i'm like i need a new job
and and he was he was fine with that
in all fairness to him he never tried
again
you can watch more of mercedes
stevenson's exclusive interview tomorrow
on the west block
as part of global's continuing
investigation to allegations of sexual
misconduct
within the canadian defense community
support is slipping tonight for new
york's governor
several high-ranking democrats are
joining calls for andrew cuomo to resign
over accusations of sexual harassment
and allegations his administration
under-reported coven-19 deaths in
nursing homes but cuomo
still won't resign jennifer johnson has
the latest on the political crisis
in new york the calls for new york
governor andrew cuomo to resign are
growing louder
most from democrats the majority of new
york's representatives in congress
including congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
and senate majority leader chuck schumer
are telling him to go
but cuomo isn't budging i'm not going to
resign
i was not elected by the politicians i
was elected by the people
cuomo faces allegations of sexual
harassment and misconduct
from seven women including lindsay
boylan who says the governor gave her an
unwanted kiss on the lips and made
uncomfortable remarks
we do not have accountability when the
governor of this state
preys on women mostly younger than
myself
and then lies about it new york's mayor
a political rival of cuomo's
says he's been flooded with calls for
the governor to resign
after news reports cuomo staffers are
allegedly trying to silence
his accusers unfortunately what we're
seeing here is a pattern
of cover up and a pattern of lies it is
unacceptable the governor must resign
he can no longer do the job with cuomo
refusing to leave
state lawmakers have launched an
impeachment investigation
a grouping allegation by one accuser has
been referred to albany police
the new york attorney general is
conducting its own investigation
there are now two reviews underway
no one wants them to happen
more quickly and more thoroughly than i
do
let them do it but one former aide
believes these sexual allegations are
just the tip of the iceberg
i'm just saying that it wasn't a safe
space for young women to work
or women in general several lawmakers
have called on cuomo to resign this
weekend
for now he continues to deny the
allegations while calling some of the
women's stories
gut wrenching jennifer johnson global
news
washington amazon canada
says it will appeal the temporary
closure of its plant in brampton ontario
because of a coven 19
outbreak the region's health authority
ordered the shutdown yesterday
nearly 5 000 employees are now required
to self-isolate for 14 days
since october there have been 617 cases
at the facility
but the worry is that 40 of them were
detected in the last couple of weeks
and that includes cases involving
variants of concern
italians are preparing to go into
lockdown again
on monday much of the country will be
under tougher coven 19 restrictions
the move is aimed at stopping an
alarming surge in cases
in recent days infections have soared
above twenty thousand cases
daily and as our europe bureau chief
crystal commansing reports
every effort is being made to ensure
this spring is not a repeat
of last year
it is a sense of deja vu for doctors in
italy
this hospital in the lombardy region was
one of many
unable to cope with the onslaught of
illness when the pandemic
first hit it
last spring's events are still fresh in
our minds says the italian prime
minister
we will do everything we can to prevent
them from happening
again daily life is already restricted
in many
regions such as compania naples famous
seaside walkways are empty along with
piazzas
and non-essential shops come monday new
strict measures could be in place across
much of italy
regions such as lombardi and lazio where
rome is located
may be shut down completely the
government updated the criteria for red
zones to include
any area with more than 250 new weekly
cases
per 100 000 people the measures are
expected to remain in place
until april 6.
i'm worried says this woman my 14 year
old daughter is working
virtually for school she is losing her
best years of adolescence like this
from morning to night she is inside the
house
in her pajamas italians have been told
for the easter weekend
they're not to leave their home unless
it's for work
health or an emergency
the prime minister acknowledged the
economic and psychological
impact of the measures
italy was the first western nation to
impose a national lockdown on march 9
2020 confining roughly 60 million people
to their homes
a year on there have been more than 101
thousand
covid 19 related deaths and national
daily infections
have been above 20 thousand
to support hospitals a new traveling
intensive care unit
is available eight converted train
coaches can transport up to 21 patients
by rail
the main train station in rome is also
doubling
as a vaccination center it was as good
as it could be
i didn't have to wait outside i was seen
by somebody who could help me with
english
the guy who administered the vaccine was
excellent
vaccines and lockdowns are the tools at
hand
it's hoped the combination will be
strong enough to prevent
a repeat of last year crystal commansing
global news
london a british police officer accused
of kidnapping and murder
appeared in court today 48-year-old
wayne cousins was arrested tuesday in
connection with the disappearance
of sarah everard the 33-year-old
vanished while walking home from a
friend's house on march
3rd on wednesday her body was found in a
wooded area
cousins became a metropolitan police
officer in 2018
and most recently served as a guard for
embassies
and parliament everard's death has
sparked outcry across the united kingdom
and around the world
several people were arrested tonight
during a vigil for everard
hundreds of people mostly women gathered
in south london for the memorial despite
police warning it would breach
coven 19 restrictions police are being
accused of
taking a heavy-handed response the u.s
australia india and japan are demanding
democracy be restored in myanmar
after security forces launched another
lethal assault
on protesters
at least 12 more people were killed in
the capital
in the city of mandalay police opened
fire on a peaceful sit-in
killing five people there is concern for
the well-being of aung san tsuchi
two members of her party died while in
custody the united nations says at least
70 people have been murdered since the
military launched its coup
in february the true toll is likely much
higher
coming up a word from the wise as she
reflects
on two pandemics and later on global
national a stress release
for health care workers
the vaccination campaign across the
country is picking up steam
more provinces are now expanding
eligibility to younger age groups
but today canada's oldest citizen
received her shot
phyllis ridgway just turned 114 and as
catherine ward reports
family members can't wait until they can
finally give her a hug
the pace was slow and steady outside
toronto's sunnybrook hospital saturday
people 80 years and older lining up to
get their first
round of vaccines and leaving with
envelopes booked for their second dose
phyllis ridgeway was all smiles getting
out of the car i actually haven't seen
her this happy and excited in quite some
time there has been much to celebrate as
phyllis turned 114 on wednesday
and holds the honor of being the oldest
living person
on record in canada i'm so absolutely
grateful and happy that we're able to do
this today
and get that vaccine her arm phyllis
still lives in her home
so this phase of the vaccine rollout was
her earliest
shot at the shot
leaving the hospital phyllis gave the
whole process a five-star rating
oh my goodness i just can't i'll never
get over it
it was wonderful i asked her about the
last pandemic the spanish
flu which started in 1918. you would
have been 10 years old when that
happened
oh yes but you know it didn't seem to
affect us
very much or maybe i was too young to
i don't know what to really remember
memories from long ago slightly faded
and replaced with matters of the day
her family now so thankful their beloved
matriarch
is one step closer to protection from
covid19
it's always very odd when i go to visit
and from a distance you just say
bye grandma you know it'll be nice to
actually just give her a nice long hug
her parting advice to others who are
considering the vaccine
if it's going to help of course they
should get it
katherine ward global news
toronto still ahead
waste not the top chefs being hailed as
food bank heroes
during this pandemic thousands of
canadians suddenly found themselves
struggling to buy food
that put pressure on food banks but a
pair of chefs cooked up an amazing
concept to help
and it quickly turned into a year of
remarkable kindness
here's mike drillet cool down a little
bit
just pull that skin right off chef keith
[ __ ] had an epiphany a few years ago
he was teaching the culinary arts at
thistletown collegiate
in toronto's rexdale neighborhood yet he
wanted to do something positive in the
community
so why not he thought blend the two so
every month his students would get a
healthy dose of cooking and
learning to be a good global citizen by
preparing a
full meal for a youth or women's shelter
there's no way
better to show that you care about
somebody than to prepare a meal for them
i think
it's one of the real ways that you show
respect and love
finding ways to put ingredients together
seems to be his thing
he did it masterfully when he won chop
canada so that means you
chef keith [ __ ] are our chopped canada
champion and you're gonna make a lot of
kids happy because you just won ten
thousand dollars congratulations that's
fantastic
and last march when he and fellow chef
john placo began getting calls about
massive amounts of unused food from
restaurants and colleges
they used their own cars to deliver it
to local food banks
but it's when they discovered many of
the kitchens that provide meals
for seniors and people with disabilities
had been closed
that they really got to work so the two
chefs along with their wives began
preparing meals and desserts
in their home kitchens how many hours a
day were you in the kitchen
cooking oh probably probably
10 or 12 hours a day it was non-stop it
was from morning till night
six seven days a week yeah it was
non-stop so we're probably up at about
40 to 50
000 you know meals that we've sent out
to
shelters and food banks between four
people between four people yeah
that doesn't seem remarkable at all
their charity proved to be contagious
and well over a dozen major suppliers
stepped up to donate
it's definitely helped me sleep better
at night knowing that it's uh
it's been gone to a great cause
they estimate they've so far diverted a
million dollars of food from landfills
as chefs they hate to see good food
wasted
but that pales in comparison to how they
feel about people going hungry
microleg global news toronto
and you can see more on these chefs
tonight on the new reality with donna
friesen
right here on global up next the
relaxation
station how a quebec business is helping
hospital staff
take a load off
the who flagged the growing issue of
workplace burnout in 2019.
back then studies showed nine in 10
canadian workers
felt it then the pandemic hit the
greatest impact is on health care
workers
who've been working non-stop since no
doubt they're exhausted
and two entrepreneurs in montreal have
devised a way to help them
recharge and relax amanda delawicki
explains
this is the zero gravity position that i
was talking to you about timothy regnie
demonstrates how to use his relaxation
pod
it's a place to take a quick break
during the work day we are human being
we work a lot but we need to rest
sometimes the pod is called
recharge me kanye and his partner eric
normundo founded their company a few
years ago
realizing the nine-to-five grind proved
difficult for many
chronic stress anxiety burnout
depression
so it's it's very it's very hard for
everyone so we need that
25 minutes per day to disconnect
from that toxic routine and to recharge
the pods are small only 21 square feet
they're equipped with a zero gravity
chair light therapy
meditative music and air filters users
book 25 minute slots on an app
with strict cleaning instructions so
when i'm done i just have to
use another wipe to clean after me
they had been renting their pods to
montreal businesses when coveted hit
they pivoted focusing on hospitals and
burned out healthcare workers instead
when you work that with that intensity
you you have to you you have to rest you
need to rest orderly frederick sovay
uses the pod regularly
she faces long days constantly on her
feet
you go back on your day and you're
already more
active and it's easier for you to finish
your day
regnie believes covid will fundamentally
change how people approach their work
days
this level of productivity impacts our
mental wellness that's why we have to
bring
like this kind of initiative into the
companies
they hope to expand beyond hospitals
believing when office workers return
they'll need regular breaks too amanda
jellowicky
global news montreal no doubt we could
all use
that that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill
a reminder to set your clocks one hour
ahead for daylight saving time
we leave you tonight with a trip around
the world at toronto's ice fest
there are more than 50 sculptures made
from 30
000 kilograms of ice thank you for
watching and i'll see you back here
tomorrow
have a great night
you